Good news for coffee lovers and environmentalists alike.
Starbucks is making another move to help the world look a little greener.
Here's WJBK.
The coffee chain is continuing its push to go green.
Starting today, the coffee giant will offer customers a reusable plastic cup for one dollar.
The goal of these new cups?
To make sure fewer grande and venti cups wind up in landfills.
The reusable tumblers will mimic Starbucks paper cups, showcasing its traditional logo.
As with any reusable cup,...
...Starbucks customers will continue getting ten cents off each time they bring it in for a refill.
And you can even have them cleaned.
Going green has been a longtime focus for Starbucks,...
...but Fox business says the company appears to have set its goals a little too high.
They're hoping that will increase the habit for other people and...
...go green, the whole thing.
In 2008, Starbucks had said it wanted to serve 25 percent of all drinks in reusable cups by 2015.
The goal now has been reduced to five percent.
In reality, Starbucks served 1.9 percent of its drinks in personal tumblers...
...in its global company-owned stores in 2011.
For Newsy, I'm Megan Murphy.
Multiple sources, the real story.